ah the entrancing ballet of the
jellyfish so graceful so efficient
scientists have long known how economic
jellyfish locomotion is but a new study
exposes a hidden energy-saving trick
that the creatures use to get around the
ocean
it looks like jellyfish are kicking to
move around but really they in an
unrelated and horrifying creature called
a lamprey actually pull themselves
through the water look at this video the
researchers made the red part on the
lamprey is high pressure normal for a
critter cutting through the water with
the blue stuff that's low pressure it
turns out that the undulations of
jellyfish and lamprey bodies create low
pressure vortices like you find in the
eye of a hurricane or tornado that
resulting low pressure sucks in water
helping propel the creatures and the
suction is so powerful and it's the
dominant force in the animals forward
thrust
let's see your Dyson do that because
jellyfish and lampreys are so distantly
related the researchers reckon that this
trick of physics may be widespread in
the animal kingdom and not just in the
oceans bird wings may actually exploit
it as well given the creatures an extra
little kick and the discovery could work
its way into machines if engineers can
figure out how to create these pockets
of low pressure on boats the vessels
could save fuel so thank you little
jellyfish for your beauty and efficiency
now enough with the stinging already
you